okay hi everyone welcome to
another
wolfram language design review this is
part of our series on language
completeness and consistency
and
we are about to look at several
different things
so
we're looking first at
sub values and default values which i
guess i had
reluctantly agreed that sub values
should be a documented thing after how
many years is it
we had sub values in inversion point h
or something
um
okay
because the list of transformation rules
goes into all sub-values
right so
the the
the tentative
usage box is what i'm proposing as the
new usage box to match how we
you know match the language on up values
and down values
what do we say about values
that's not very helpful is it
that's extremely unhelpful i mean this
was probably written in in
wow it wasn't even then version one
weird
okay it's a very unhelpful thing we
really should say here i mean this is
just unfriendly i think we should use
this i think we should use this thing
values for f of x blah blah blah et
cetera
okay
and i think we should add something here
you know paren
values of
um
right it's g of f
right it's sort of hard to write because
it's sort of g of well g of f dot dot
dot comma
well g of dot dot dot f dot dot dot dot
right
i think that's enough
and i think for the sub values the thing
we should write is f of dot dot dot
ah what am i doing
dot dot dot
like that
camera etc
so i think we should do that
okay
okay
fine
default values
again i think we should put this in
there i think it's just totally obscure
without it
all right and this is primarily used in
uh
pattern matching right it's only used in
pattern matching right
i think we should say
we should make that very clear in these
notes
there's only for pattern matching it's
not the case it's not going to evaluate
to its default value
it is the
actually this is wrong i mean we should
say
something like to all default argument
values
right that's what it is right
transformation
corresponding to all
look why don't we say
corresponding to
all
values for default of f which is what
this is default of f comma dot dot dot
all values of default of f
giving default values of arguments of f
i would say arguments 2f that's fine
okay okay
all right
onward we go
graph vertices is there an issue here
right so
uh charles responded saying that he
thinks that this is all just because of
the bug which i believe has now been
fixed he can okay well let's just verify
that and let's see whether so in the
prototype build charles or somewhere
else
um yes should be the prototype
okay or the latest master
well
uh i gotta
re-verify the prototype build well i
know whether it's worth it'll be done in
a moment
uh
do you have an example you could create
in chat where we could just try this
um
white so i can send an example sure yeah
why do i have to click on this 17 times
to get it to start up what's going on
this is another
what is going on
is that
wait a second oh it's still spinning
look at that
something's really wrong with the with
the
um with startup for these prototype
versions
all right
okay what do i do
should i just say graph
um i just sent christopher here does he
have an example maybe i send an example
there
okay
well it's the case i'm talking about uh
was taking his next calf
well i guess there's nest crap and then
there was also are we talking about nest
graph are we talking about the general
stuff about addressing lists of vertices
i think we're talking about both things
okay so what's this so this is now
that's
that that's that
um
but i think your version is probably not
the one up to date the second one should
give the first argument the first vertex
should be a list that's the thing
yeah it preserved the list everywhere
else but not in the first i don't know
if that's a rendering issue or well
let's look let's see vertex
list of that
yeah i just did the wrong thing yes your
builds doesn't seem to have it
why am i well i feel unconvinced about
all of this okay well oh yeah that's an
old bill well he'd walk on my build yeah
that's all oh it's like that's like
millions of years ago that's like
ancient
okay
let's see if my
head branch build is any more recent or
maybe my
mathematica is supposed to often oh
great
should i report this or do i just ignore
this
shall i try it again
well that's not encouraging should i try
the um okay do you know what build
number so it's the mathematical building
in 618 prototype building ending in six
one eight i think that should have it
let me check what i do i think though
that that the real at least the one that
i'd encountered before was the issue
where
um
which i think is is more ambiguous which
is there's a usage of nest graph where
the function returns a list and where
that creates a branch in the graph
um it's like there's a documentation
example i think where you have like uh
you know the function
list f hash comma g of hash ampersand
right yeah right which is a very
important example for for nest graph
yes but i guess it's of course it's
ambiguous do you mean one vertex that is
a list or do you need two vertices
right
okay
is that that's yesterday's build yeah
and and that particular bug is known and
will be fixed in tonight's build
okay so there it still curlies okay so
now let's consider christopher's case
f of hash
actually let me do the the um
i see so
let's be beautiful here
um
okay
all right so that has to work right and
it does work
but now what if you so right and that
that is one behavior that you might want
but there's another behavior which is
you know
right i mean if you if you want to the
output is a single argument a single
vertex that is a list i don't think it's
a bug i think it's just ambiguous
right so what happens if we do this
so i think we should get a list of
yeah i think we get the the um
um
that doesn't seem bad
i mean so long as this is documented
that seems like to get a list as output
you just have to have its nest graph is
going to assume that the outer level
list
is
uh
multiple
branches and if you want right so you
need an extra level of list if you want
it to be a singleton list
right does this solve the problem
christopher do you think this is i think
that that that seems that seems like it
works yeah i mean maybe then the other
question would be if there's a similar
if that aligns with the behavior of uh
for example uh i i don't know vertex um
any of the functions where the second
argument is a vertex like like
annotation values an especially
hard one but yeah
okay this is an interesting case oh okay
so it's the same deal basically here
so we just have to document that but a
list
either in the inet or in the
values
the outer level list
okay here's the here's the deal the
outer level list
is always a multi so to speak
but as a courtesy if it isn't an outer
level list if there isn't an outer level
list it will not
produce a bug it will just assume it's a
single term
that a correct statement charles
yes and we actually have something
similar in the details already
and what
in the documentation okay
okay well fine let me just look at it
yep i think we should just probably show
the in our list i mean this type of
example impossible issue in case why
someone want to
but we need to say in the in the details
that it always takes the outer level
list to represent branching
yep he's written actually
okay okay
okay but then then we should give it an
early documentation example
under scope or something
or generalization maybe that that gives
well whatever you you decide you figure
it out
okay
um
okay so now the next question was a so
great this is fixed wonderful next
question
what about um
so what was the thing about a graph
whose lists are vertices
and then
um and then functions that
expect a list of vertices
do you understand what i'm saying so
what i'm saying is
let's say
um
vertex out component
okay so let's say we have a graph
and so we have a graph here and let's
say we have random integer
well let's just do this
okay there's our random graph
and now we say vertex out component of
that graph
comma
okay so let's say eight five here
that would be
okay that did fine so what if you also
have the vertices eight and five in that
graph
right we need to look at that
but but now let me just check that this
works eight five comma
two three
oh it's supposed to be a single vertex
is that correct yes
well well i just did an example on my
computer i did give it a list of
vertices
oh right thank you thank you thank you
thank you yes
yes yeah okay fine
so there is a yes right so you can give
that
okay so now let's give our graph where
we have a um
um
you just use like vertex add if you
really wanted to
i was just going to do table i j i goes
to
um
oh god i have to catenate that table
by the way if anybody can think of a
heuristic to decide whether you should
be using catinate or
whatever
okay magnificent
so now
i want to do the same thing vertex out
combined with that
oh eight five doesn't have to be there
anymore so let's do one zero
there's no vertex 0
i know
but okay so that's that
okay so now let's see what happens if we
do vertex
1 0 comma 1.
not bad
so they are just the you know we first
take the vertex we check if it's a valid
vertex so do if you are you know a valid
vertex you take precedence over the list
and then we throw it inside
right i think this is fine i mean you
should have something impossible issues
for the very very weird case in which
there's ambiguity between
a
you know a pair
like i could imagine if you were doing a
collection of subsets
rather badly you might have singletons
together with
um
together with the aggregated ones and
that could cause trouble
does that make sense
um
yes yes
so that that's just impossible issues
okay so if you try like three two
for what where um there's a vertical
second argument
oh i said you're saying
okay so that is vertex 3 2
but it might not be
so is there a way you could ask i mean
how would you ask for
the the list 3 2 and not the vertex 3 2.
that makes sense add the list around
but it has to be list 3 list 2 right
no no
no no but the question is what happens
if you want the list of vertices 3 and
2.
yes yes
and how can you get that
do you see what i'm saying i mean this
is the suggestion to do
map list across that list
well i don't think that's going to work
but but
no no
because it is not so
i think you can't get there from here
i think it's an obscure case and the
syntax is not devastating i think we
should just document it
i mean i'm not thrilled but i think it i
think it'd be good to show examples in
which
yeah
i mean i i don't know what do other
people think i i don't see a way to get
around this
just for fun can you try list list 322
list list
three two
two
like that no
double up the two
like that
i predict this is just gonna error out
what else would it do
uh
yeah i guess so one level of the outer
lip
if i get rid of the outer list
then what that should do
is give me the components
yeah that will give me the components in
this graph
okay while we're at it on graph
complaining
okay
um
i would have said while we're on the
complaining path
and modified that world around the
complaining graph anyway
um
the
here's the thing that gets me every
single time i have a directed graph
and i do a highlight graph
let's say okay let's take let's take
this
um
oops what happened to me here oh i gotta
forget the cat
okay magnificent
okay
now
i say
oh yeah i've got another complaint about
placed by the way before we forget
um okay so now i'm going to take a path
here i'm going to say
um
i don't know
find path
of that graph
comma
i don't know six comma one let's say
that's not what i want
where is there a path in this graph can
somebody just see what wait a minute
there's a path from six to one isn't
there oh i did i said once
oh it's direct path i want a path from
maybe pick a sparser graph
yes okay let's just do a random graph
okay
oh but i need a directed graph for this
to work
so can i do that with directed edges
arrow true there yes yes
okay
okay
let's say
oh god i'm gonna find a path there
okay fine that's enough okay
so now i want to say highlight graph
okay
of
percent 27
comma
and then i want that path
and i say path graph
of
percent 28.
what the heck path graph of percent 28
doesn't work you don't find shortest
path i think it might work i mean you
you probably wanted to say you know list
one comma seven comma ten and it still
will not work right because i think
that's what you are trying to i like
that
the part graph will generate on the
righted graph where the graph have
directed graph and then we don't
highlight them
sorry so that again the path graph will
generate a
a directed or an undirected graph
why
why why doesn't graph highlight graph
if it sees if it sees the the template
of what it is trying to highlight
as being an undirected version of the
directed graph why doesn't it highlight
it
we we can't do that i think it's
i mean we're just systematic in terms of
the second argument should be a sub
graph
or a list of edge or vertex of the you
know the actual existing graph
right but so so the the issue here is is
a directed edge
does it read on an undirected edge so to
speak does an undirected edge read on a
directed edge and i claim the answer
should be yes
so i mean maybe maybe the question is i
mean if you gave uh if the second
argument of the highlight graph had
instead of an undirected edge it had two
directed edges one going each direction
then it would highlight them i mean we
have the case of mixed half
white
well you know you have a graph which can
have you know undirected and directed
and then which one do you want to
highlight
well right now if you do a sub graph
it'll highlight both of them
um i'm not sure i understand you mean
well the difficulty is okay look right
now this is every single time it's like
you know upper creek no paddle type
thing okay
every single time i do this i get
confused i end up using a sub graph sub
graph highlights too many edges because
i just want the path i don't want
the extra
sorry go ahead because because then what
ends up happening is i do a sub graph
with those vertices but that's not good
enough because i actually want i want
the graph
that is
what is that what is that object that it
is a it is a a fragment of a directed
graph consistent with a given undirected
graph which is not a sub graph is it
yes
yes
so what is it what is that object
no no no
i'm asking the following question
i've got a directed graph okay
i then say
okay one thing i can do is i can say
give me the sub graph of the directed
graph with these vertices okay that will
be completely different than saying take
this undirected graph with its with its
edges
and
tell me
use that as a sort of cookie cutter or
something on the directed graph and ask
what piece of the directed graph
including edges do i get out from that
cookie cutter
right that's the question so and that's
what we're not doing correctly here
so to speak
um
maybe one way we you know we can still
say you know maybe we can um you know
set up the you know we can add directed
edge to be automatic in this case
and then we say okay you know since the
you know person 27 there is a directed
graph we assume what you are giving
is the sub induced
by that
that makes sense that makes sense that
the directed edge
where directed at george manic where
um for highlight cuff
is there a way of getting this to work
what i did by just changing the options
to highlight graph here
so
so
just to make sure i understand so if you
replace percent 28 and that input with
the list
one goes to seven seven goes to ten
does that do what you want
you want to say graph instead of path
graph
i mean
not not the edge actually this
i like the new pink
no see what you need to put is one comma
seven comma ten
right because here you infer that the
part graph is directed
i think your usual example you do pad
graph one comma seven comma ten
right not with the holes
right because that's a directed path
graph that i got there
so i think there's multiple issues
because i think when you actually run
path graph of percent 28 percent 28 is a
list of lists
it's like a list of of paths not a
single path
but right but this is the case where
there is the actual issue
right
right so what why on earth did it do
what it did there because the vertices
go inside but not the edges right
so if you really instantiate this part
graph right you have a list of vertices
one comma seven comma ten and then you
have a list of on the right at edge
one seven cent and those those
undirected don't appear in
percent twenty seven that's the thing
right but so do you think you have a
solution for this charles
um well my proposal was to do the you
know have the right directed edge of
highlight graph to be automatic
why would that help i mean sorry i
didn't understand directed edge
graph to be automatic
and then from there we'll just you know
look at your you know
so wait a minute if i say directed edges
automatic here does that do anything
does that mean anything right now no
we don't have any automatic
but do we have a directed edges
so what do we do what happens if i say
directed edge is false
i'm confused about what is directed
edges doing in highlight graph
not pretty much nothing
okay fine
but so what you're proposing is
that
if highlight graph
what are you proposing does past graph
take directed edges could it yes because
so if you just add that director that
just goes through to the path graph that
would
fix the issue for you i believe so yes
that will fix it which is the same as
the whole above
right
so as i was proposing that the
heightened edge automatic
you know just look at the
you know the actual graph you want to
highlight
and adjust the path you know the
right-hand side whatever you put there i
think that's the right thing to do
because i think people just don't expect
if you say highlight graph a graph
and all you get
is the
remaining smile of the cheshire cat of
its of its vertices
it doesn't really seem right
i agree yeah
right i mean i i have
i don't have a deep objection but i am a
bit concerned as to then what
do directed edges go to true and false
mean in highlight graph
well it's a good question okay so what
what should that do
in in in principle the documentation of
directed edge mean
how we interpret holes
right
or how we convert a graph to you know
whose you know directed edge of i mean
when we want to set the calf
based on the input to be true i mean
directed on the right
yeah okay so what does it mean if
directed edges is true in highlight
graph what does that mean
um nothing because the graph
best you know in this case person 27
take precedence in terms of
the interpretation of the oh so you mean
if highlight graph had a first argument
that was just a list of rules
then directed edges would determine
yup you should
well okay so let me just understand
something
if i say
graph
of
let's say 1 goes to 2 2 goes to 3
comma directed edges
goes to false
oh i see
whereas normally hold on
what does this do normally
i see it produces a directed graph and
directed edges false makes it undirected
okay so directed edges are automatic
in highlight graph
well what's that really going to do
i mean it still has to decide what to do
with
so then we
essentially we assume the
second argument which should be the sub
graph or part of the graph
right that's you know essentially it
will be you know the sub graph with you
know directed edge goes to two or the
height attached goes to false
based on the type of calf you have the
right hand side yeah i understand you
mean on the first argument
yes
it's a little bit heuristic-y
but it's got it's better than what we do
right now which is just crazy
i mean it's unclear to me why it does
anything that is why does the path graph
by the time
i don't understand why the vertices
agree
it's one thing to just say sorry your
graph doesn't match
how can the vertices agree but not the
edges that's my question so
theoretically we we take the part graph
what we essentially we break it in two
parts you have the vertex list and then
the edge list
that's pretty much what we do
the question is do you consider
a
a
right i mean the the point is do you
consider a directed edge to intersect
with an undirected edge i think the
answer is right now the answer is no and
that might be consistent across all the
graph functions in which case this is
probably the right behavior right yes
i mean
it's highlighting all the it's
highlighting all the places where the
two graphs that you've given it
intersect and right now because directed
edges are different from undirected
edges they do not intersect on the edges
but they do intersect at the vertices
right
right do we do we allow um
you know mixed graphs of directed and
undirected edges yes yes
right and so then i think we're running
into potential problems with this right
i mean right it's very clear right now
even though it may be annoying to you
stephen it's it's the consistent and
clear behavior right the
the edges are the vertices are the same
but the edges don't match
yeah
well okay fair enough i mean
that's just so weird though
i mean maybe because there's a common
case though which is apart from from
path graph right there's a common case
of just i have a list of vertices
representing a path and i want to
highlight that path in a graph so maybe
there would be some syntax for doing it
without using path graph i don't know
exactly what it would be
right
how you can provide a list of vertices
maybe you could somehow
the problem is a list of vertices it's
just going to say highlight those points
in the graph
right
um
my fundamental point is just that the
creation of that intermediate path graph
is is not important in this case right
all that all that matters is just that
you're you're basically telling it
highlight the edges
between these vertices
[Music]
well maybe
do we need a directed graph path that
just takes the list of vertices and
creates you know does the partition
and mapping and application of rule to
create well that's just park off with
directed edges goes to true as an option
yeah
i mean i don't know i i don't know what
this would be but like if you could have
some
like this itself could work but you
could have like path graph arrow you
know directed edges are all or something
and it and the point being that it would
highlight the undirected edges and the
directed edges and tagged edges and you
know
all the edges between these pairs of
vertices and of course you wouldn't want
to do that through path graph
right i mean that's maybe another
question what about tagged edges so if
you have a
if i say um highlight graph and i want
to highlight the edge one undirected
edge three and there's only one
undirected edge three but with a tag
will that highlight that edge or does it
not highlight it because technically
they're different respond to the tag
charles what does it do in terms of
matching these up with tags
um
that's a good point
in principle
you shouldn't highlight if you don't
have the tag right because you know yeah
right that's right you basically would
want to
um
which seems like it's probably the right
behavior but it might also be useful if
you could just tell it i don't care
about directedness i don't care about
tags just highlight this path just
because it's a relatively common case
again i don't know what the syntax would
be though right but i mean i but clearly
highlighting what happens if you want to
highlight okay
how do i highlight only those edges with
tag foo
um you can use pattern in principle for
all those
so you can do on you can do on the right
at edge
you know
pattern comma pattern comma four
really
yes
so like that
yep
this is a stupid question that's a dumb
edge case but what if you have a vertex
which is an undirected edge if that
makes sense
maybe that's a dumb case
that's a weird case but it's amusing
but it's it's actually happened because
i mean we encounter it with line graph
normally you know line graph is popular
dual i mean the value switch of you know
the edge becomes the vertex
right
and in some case you actually want that
so you have a
vertex which is an edge and then an edge
an edge
right
um
boy given all the activities we've had
recently i mean i have to tell you we
are going to have to do hyper graphs and
we're going to have to do graph
rewriting before very long just so you
know okay
we've got tons of code for it it's not
like it isn't you know it's not it's
well explored and we've got lots of code
for it
um
but it will be non-trivial to design it
uh okay so what are we gonna do with
this
um are we going to just document this
and we could document it and find find
path we could just show
very early on an example of how to
display you know the path within a graph
that might at least solve part of the
problem
using path graph for the directed edge
goes to true
but it don't it's not my favorite it's
really not my favorite i mean
okay can we think think one more one
more round about this um
the issue is
when does it care about the annotation
of an edge
right does highlight graph consider the
graph that is matching
to
does it require matching of the edgery
so to speak
to decide that it is a match to the to
the graph
does that make sense
so in other words it's a graph
this is a graph that almost matches but
doesn't quite but the very fact that it
thinks the vertices match is what blows
my mind like it's not like the graph
doesn't match at all it matches only by
its you know by its feet its vertices so
to speak
that's what i find really weird
because actually when you look at the
documentation of highlight curve we
didn't actually explicitly say that you
can
give a graph by to give a vertex or
edges
when you give a graph a paragraph it's
just kind of a generalization where we
instantiate it and then we compute the
vertex list edge list right well then so
we are at liberty in that case to simply
decide that path graph
ignores directedness
yep well do we know that it's a path
graph
i mean or is there any record of the
fact that
as a path
no
honestly it kind of sounds like the
current behavior is the right behavior
but that maybe there should be some
other way of
some other weird syntax for for doing
this
well we could make it a little bit we
could have a directed path graph
function
it's a little bit crazy but not totally
crazy i mean we have directed graph
and we have
graph we have yeah i don't think that
will solve your problem though because
you can already say directed edges are
true i mean i think your problem is just
that you're going to want to say path
graph and then you know it doesn't work
and then you're gonna have to switch to
directed path graph but you could just
as easily just add directed edges arrow
true yeah but then how do you even know
that you have
um path graph so to speak i mean
how do you even know you have to do path
graph you just give
i think this just needs to be in the
documentation for
for fine path i think that's the place
to start
okay
okay
all right
what's next extract
okay so
um we have what was the thing that came
up recently i'm sorry well we said we
wanted it to test
oh yes yes i want to talk about placed
for a second okay text has ridiculous
non-documentation documentation
um
let me show it to you
place has no example of so it makes this
obscure statement
that um
okay typical supportive forms include as
well as special positions
and explicit lists of scale coordinates
okay how does that work
it have it's per
you know scenario
how does it work in graph for example
where do i find the documentation of
that
um
vertex label
should have solved
not looking promising charles
um there there is label and
place well okay
it's gonna save does it
right and then the last item in that
table is
some description of what the
numeric forms are
scaled position
so that's like an inset
yes
well it's like text it's similar to text
all right i admit it's documented okay
and and we've i mean actually over the
past year or year and a half or
something we've been
sort of
filling it out in more dots so if you
look at like bar chart for example
okay
um it has i think i hope i hope you have
a oh it has a diagram that would be
useful
see
nice
nice
oh well i think that's just what it
needs for these other things
fine okay user error
okay there was something we were talking
about being extract like recently
that was in the
um
lists of vertices lists and graph
vertices discussion
oh which is now over because because
that was just a bug basically right
okay fine all right so now we're talking
about extract itself
right
incidentally what has earth has happened
to the um
inserted the whole business about adding
to arrays and so on
the thing that etienne originally was
was talking about
you know what i'm talking about the
ability to go
like listable goes at the top level with
respect to operators like plus the
ability to go at the bottom level with
operators like plus
i i think
well go ahead jose
yes we just
worked on something else but it's it's
still
planned
okay fine it's planned in your team
somehow or is it
um
not sure it's
i mean i think it requires deeper
support probably from rob
for the stability things
fair enough but um
but who's going to lead it is your
are you involved in that or is that do
we have i am
i am involved but but i i don't think we
we managed to agree on a
complete design we got one very close i
think we're very close yes yes let's
iterate it again and try and nail that
design yeah yeah
it was a good it's a really good thing
it'll be very useful like splice like
nothing and so on these are very useful
things
um
okay
part specs and extract
extract is the inverse of position that
exact simatic we claim
right
okay so
what is the point here
um
okay go ahead
right so so
right
the point is that you know people have
you know wanted things like all in
extract but all obviously is something
that would never be returned by position
um
and so you know we've had sort of some
inconsistent support
uh not documented and now we have a
branch where it is
um
sort of consistently implemented
so this is a review of that supposedly
consistent implementation is that
correct correct
okay
right so and you know there are a couple
of
issues mentioned there and i've also
added a tentative note to the
documentation
okay what is part association so part
with that matt
um
if i just take that matrix and i say
part
all comma one
then i get that
yep and normally
extract
would
i'm very confused by something if i say
here extract this comma one comma two
right
right that's what that's what i would
expect
okay
and in order to get
the thing that i'm was thinking i was
getting it would be this
right uh yes you
right okay
first and third columns independently
that's nice i mean is there any problem
with that that seems like the right
thing yeah i don't think so
okay this is
right so since it's so since it's not a
list of lists it's treated as a single
you know part back and so this is doing
the same thing as you would get as part
of matt
comma all comma list one three
okay so if i were to do that
as matt
all one three i will get the same thing
good yep okay so now
if i were to get
if i did one two
oops
okay
right and and now if you gave that in a
list to
uh extract
yes you'll get something different
interesting
right because you gave it a list of
things i now understand why it happened
anybody have comments here is
christopher still here does he ever
comment on this
here but i don't have an immediate
comment
does it horrify you isn't that different
a bit yeah
well it's because part
accepts the list of more fitnesses
i know and i know i know why it happens
i mean i think i think it's one of these
cases where
there is going to be a corner case
that's a little bit horrifying but on
the other hand it's probably the right
thing it's probably useful okay so
that's one weird thing and that should
be documented in possible issues
presumably right no it's actually it's
it's logical if of course it's logical
no no i mean it's not a possible issue
it can be recommended properly
because
my plan my plan is both both the
documented under properties and
relations as a positive and also
as a possible issue that it's different
right like that it's different is a
possible issue
right okay okay so now what's this i
mean that this is basically the same
issue i just instead of all i wrote the
list one two three
oh my gosh that's a more horrifying case
right now you can get it to work with an
extra level of list
right because then you have a list of
lists and it looks inside of each
list as a sequence of part specs
i understand
now this coefficient that we are seeing
here has always been there
now
this particular case the list of lists
is the main purpose of extract i know
this is this is what position could
return
it is the other cases that
are bringing extract closer to part and
that are a bit strange in there but they
have been always there what we have done
here is simply to be more consistent
because some users had complained that
for example mapat had a more extensive
support of
uh of this language
which is correct
and so now extract is is closer to what
mapat can right yes so map and extract
are consistent
uh now now they are closer
in fact i think we have made in this
branch extract to be even more powerful
than
okay so what's the thing that extract
can do that map cannot do
well i
personally i think
looking at it i think
i think it's a bug and map happy so in
map at if you have
like a number and then a list of numbers
it works but if you have it in the other
order it doesn't i think
a number and a list of numbers
i see
okay fine so that should be looked at
okay but so then then
position and i think position returns
extract can eat and so you can map at
but extract has some additional
conveniences
that are beyond what position can return
correct
okay
and it has a different behavior because
it isn't verags among other things
from from part
correct
okay
in terms of i mean in terms of its outer
producting behavior so to speak
right
okay i don't see a problem with this
yeah if you give it a list of lists
um in the second argument then you would
get the list of parts where you turned
each of the inner lists into a sequence
to give it to part
yep
so
right you got that list of parts i i
think we're good here
okay there is one issue which is sort of
an implementation issue so it's really
uh do we care
which is uh up till now extract has
supported you know one dot and just sort
of cast it to an integer
um and now that's been lost and so the
question is how much do we care i think
it was unbelievably freaking weird that
it worked
okay
i would never have expected that to work
okay
i suspect that worked because of some
you know avoidance of some issue with
the compiler or some other weird thing
like that does anybody else here i mean
i if you if you'd quizzed me with that
work i would have said not a chance
anybody else disagree
no i was very surprised to know that
what
it extracts supports uh 14 points
because part supports 14.
you can't be serious after all these
years
like if i say
one point yeah
really
right now i think if you did like 2.1 it
would yell at you but
the special case of two dot
and
and so i'm a little bit worried about
breaking user code
um yeah it does seem a little concerning
i mean i would have no idea this would
have worked
right and and i'm wondering if it's
because you know if you're inside of n
then maybe your numbers oh yes right
better not break that
i mean i hope it isn't even documented
it's not
all right well we'll we'll try to fix it
and you know just to not break user code
but there was no plan to document it
okay
uh
okay boolean operators treat one and
zero symbolically
right so if you do zero or one you get
zero or one and if you do zero or true
then you get true
right right right zero one are
not
things of the of the boolean world
correct
okay but boolean table
of let's say
you know an or
of a b
comma a b is that how it works
uh you have yeah
i think normally you would put the you
put you put parentheses around like you
uh
it works
this way it should release this type
okay
okay so now what is the proposal here
well so
you and
[Music]
somebody else complained about the fact
that if you put 0 or 1 instead of a or b
in that expression it still returns the
same
result
which i think is a little weird but i
don't
yeah so you reported the bug and
and what was what was my bug
um
right so it's replace all the a's and
b's with the zero or one in in that
boolean table expression
this with with zero one here yeah
yeah
it's just a variable it's just a
variable to to to boolean operators
right and i agree that's weird but i i'm
i you know
how do i turn the true true false into
uh one one zero
well that's not too difficult
is that documented in boolean table you
should document it there i think he is
yes
oh there you go
well okay i think i probably retract any
comment i had there i think we're good
here yeah so the only inconsistency here
is that boolean function actually treats
zero as false and one is true
and this it's absolutely the only
boolean operator that does that i'm
sorry boolean function
does what
so if you do like boolean function of
three comma two which which is some
boolean function with
three variables i think if i correctly
remember there are with two variables
and now we evaluate it at zero one
it it would actually give true or false
so it will treat zero as false and one
as true
if you do boolean function of of two
comma seven which is or um which i know
because i i checked that last night um
then right so if you do a table with
zero and ones
then right so
i understand what you're doing i
understand what you're saying if the i j
is zero one it'll do something crazy
if the ij is zero one it'll do the right
thing but if it's a one and two
then it'll it won't evaluate
or or it will treat one as true but
but two is something unknown
doesn't that do anything
well it's not simple you boolean convert
will convert it to
explicit formula
i mean boolean function has leaf count
one
i see why does it convert it to
not a or not b
oh did that either
because that's just
yeah maybe i did maybe i had zero and
one backwards when i did my table okay
okay but uh
yeah so if uh
right but the point is you know you can
give it zero and one and it'll behave as
if it's
you know false and true i guess
right zero is false or is zero true zero
is false one is true
but all the other numbers are under
unrecognized
symbols okay look i think what it's
doing here as a courtesy having boolean
function works zero and one is a good
thing the insanity of having a boolean
table where the names of the variables
are zero and one is an insanity and
shouldn't be worried too much about
okay
um
now
also i see it's documented that boolean
function works with zero and one and
also you might imagine if we wanted to
support
like a higher valued logic with boolean
function like you know three valued
logic or something like that then it
makes sense for it to take numbers
exactly
and i mean for example boolean function
is consistent with cellular automaton
and cellular automaton can take
obviously more than two values i mean i
wonder whether that's something
boolean function
there are some notes about
uh about the the problem was the
original reason why why we put it there
the the zero and one to be consistent
with our command then okay there we go
so cellular thomas and n comma two comma
r is equivalent to that boolean function
right so in principle we could provide a
boolean function with with uh you know k
greater than two
and a completely it's completely obvious
what it should do is there any way to
actually add that in is that what is
form here
what's that form argument
is that things like bnf or
[Music]
oh it automatically converts converts to
to the forms that are specified in
boolean convert so it's sort of a
shortcut of not writing boolean convert
right
well in a perfect world we would add i
mean we could put it as a long time
you know we should add the the case for
higher valued logic someday
but let's not worry about that right now
okay comment on our live stream
uh
point from raffy about could part of an
operative form sadly part is varrog so
it really can't have an operator form
um
but extract does have an operative form
right correct
i didn't list any here but it's
documented and i'll make sure that there
are appropriate examples fine
and
dan or dana i heard the porous with
different number of vowels
um
suggests adding a second argument to bit
not that specifies the size of the
integer
i.e
bit
xor
i think we
oh yeah this is a whole can of worms
this is a whole horrifying can of worms
associated with the representation you
know two's complement arithmetic versus
other things
i mean i agree that there's a there's an
issue here
with an unlimited number of digits so
the question is could we add a thing
which gives the number of digits
everybody is very silent well i i
i think it was
useful
i think it would be useful
okay well so then why don't you see if
it's easy to do it may be totally
trivial to do it
um are there other functions for which
that would be relevant i don't think so
i think bitnot is the only one which
cares about the word length isn't it
but xor doesn't care
it's just a local operation on on uh
aligned digits
no i i'd right but but it knows how it
needs to know how many leading zeroes to
to negate doesn't it
that's bit that bit xor doesn't negate
anything
well well right but i i was i was i
always think oh we um
you're saying the alignment well what
i'm saying is that the alignment
i think bitnot is the only one that
cares because i think all the other
things we support
because we don't have a general bit
function
for arbitrary
i mean we could have bitwise boolean
function and then we would have this
issue for everything
but right now the only one we have is
bit not
um
that's the only
don't don't some of these right yeah
you're right but bit shift
left must have an issue
maybe so so [ __ ] left takes the the
the k argument which is right no that's
how many places to shift by the point
about bit shift left is that in
principle it could shift a digit out of
the word
right that would be a case that could
happen but bit not is an in-your-face
example of where it cares about the word
size
i mean this one also cares about the
word size potentially
both it's worth just doing the a quick
look at them and see whether it's easy
okay
to to do this
did we get through our agenda we did
amazing
good stuff
um
all right well that should be it for
this
thank you thanks everybody